alright guys bangbang super excited to
have PD on the on the podcast here I was
telling him beforehand that he gets to
spend all of his time worrying about
things that actually matter in the world
like health diet and anti-aging so
thanks so much for doing this man oh and
thanks Anthony it's my pleasure
for sure so for those that don't know
you maybe let's just start with with
your background kind of where did you
grow up and and then what did you do
through school before you you start
really creating content on the Internet
so yeah so I have a background my
education is in microbiology and
biochemistry that studied pharmacology
as well and as you know I I was pointing
out to you this is you know I'm not a
research scientist or anything like that
but it is my field so let me give you a
little bit of other background I've been
interested in health and fitness for a
long time and you know I basically
followed conventional wisdom for a long
time but then when I found myself with
an illness this has already been a
couple of decades ago and I couldn't get
better my interest definitely deepened
because I had to try to figure out how
how to take care of myself how do how do
heal myself how to improve because the
doctors couldn't do it they were getting
nowhere and I saw a number of them so
you know so I jumped in and and you know
I definitely made progress I had
definitely figured a few things out and
so I started writing about it and after
I had written about it I thought well
what do I do now I guess I'll keep
writing and keep researching and and so
on so I did that and I
in several books and then you know God
on Twitter and and that's basically you
know fast forward today Here I am yeah
and so you you obviously are incredibly
humble you've written I think six books
at this point you've got a fairly
popular blog in Rogge health and fitness
and the part to me that initially caught
my attention when I saw you tweeting a
bunch of stuff that I thought was
interesting and when I click through to
the website there's these photos of you
and one is from 2008 and the way I would
describe it for those that are just
listening is essentially you look like
kind of your standard computer
programmer right you've got basically
kind of a button-down collared shirt on
some khakis and you know overly skinny
but by no means kind of out of shape but
more of just like never been around a
weight room before and then you fast
forward to 2017 and you're like wait a
minute the guy in 2017 looks like he's
in way better shape and actually younger
than the guy in 2008 and I think that's
kind of you know a great just visual
example of the work that you've done
around hey this was actually really
really important as you get older and
naturally where you've kind of hung your
hat right right it is very important
yeah just my starting point as you
mentioned was definitely you know not
not quite where most people are starting
from these days you know I mean I was I
was on the underweight side and and that
was when I was ill as well so you know
one of the things I figured out was that
resistance training
aka weightlifting was one of the best
things I could do and I got very much
into it put on a lot of muscle right
away based basically in the first year
after I started it and started eating
differently as well so my my reading and
and studies have convinced me that that
it's that resistance training is just a
very important thing
for everyone to do whether their men are
women young or old we lose muscle as we
age this is a really underappreciated
fact that that it's Eve it's even
detectable when someone is in their 30s
and then this accelerates over the years
and it's such that by the time someone
is 80 years old they can have lost half
the muscle mass that they had when they
were young if they don't do something
about it and of course most people
aren't doing anything about it so yeah
that's a condition ona sarcopenia its
massive loss of muscle mass and then a
lot of people overlay a pretty high
amount of body fat over that and that's
that's just a health disaster I think
that this is this is the muscle part is
that is underappreciated and and
everything about that is
underappreciated you know in why why do
people get sicker as they get older and
to my mind this is you know right there
is the crux of the matter as far as why
they do metabolic dysfunction from
losing muscle excess body fat of course
the wrong kinds of foods enter into it
and on and on but you know you know
right there I tweeted something just
just this morning I was you know
thinking about this I treated that that
all chronic disease is just a
manifestation of a single cause and okay
that's that that's a huge generality I
realize but I think this is something
that is not appreciated very much that
that metabolic dysfunction that comes
from being out of shape and eating the
wrong kind of food this is what
underlies virtually everything that
people go to the doctor for the you know
the crying diseases that are seen in the
developed world
you know as opposed the acute things
that are they're more common elsewhere
so yeah that's that's a big big idea
that that I think you know is one of my
main themes that you you have to you
have to have good metabolic function to
avoid crime disease
yeah and part of what I think is so
interesting about your work is you
literally named the blog rogue health
and fitness right you're going rogue
from kind of the standard ideas around
what to eat how to exercise and things
like that and so I thought maybe what we
could do is let's start on the diet side
right most people are taught kind of a
low fat high carb type diet and they
basically eat you know what they
consider to be that food pyramid you
obviously have a different view of the
world so maybe kind of talk about the
work you've done and why you've arrived
at something that's different or kind of
rogue to those traditional
recommendations okay great
so I think that a lot of this a lot of
the way people eat and you know how
they're recommended to eat and so on it
flows from one one single light idea and
that idea is the wrong idea and and it's
basically the idea that saturated fat
causes heart disease this this goes back
to you know the forties and fifties and
and the nutritionists and selkies and
the cholesterol idea and so on and they
hit on the idea that saturated fat was
killing people it was it was a huge
problem at the time heart disease it's
still a big problem but he hits mostly
much older people now at the time they
were looking at a lot of middle-aged men
dropping dead of heart attacks and so on
so they hit on this idea and in
retrospect it you know looking at
looking at
what we know now in the research it
seems wholly mistaken nevertheless by
the late 1970s the US government had
latched on to it and put out official
dietary recommendations that we should
avoiding a lot of saturated fat that we
should eat a lot of whole grains that
fruits and vegetables were uniquely
healthy and so on and so forth and that
is basis for how how most people are
eating now I let me back up a little
front as far as saturated fat goes there
have been several meta analyses which
are basically reviews of studies done in
the last decade that have shown that
intake of dietary saturated fat is not
related to coronary heart disease so I
come from a perspective of thinking why
do why does the Western world the modern
Western world suffer from these diseases
like heart disease and cancer and
Alzheimer's diabetes and so on and and
why I have these all increased in recent
years and why do some other societies
not have them essentially you know for
example there is there's a there's an
island in the South Pacific
the Quito and the island of Catawba
where these people live and they have no
chronic disease whatsoever as far as
they found you know people have gone
there and investigate them and that
despite the fact that 75% of the men
smoked cigarettes so you know I mean I'm
not you know not saying that cigarettes
are behind by any means but I'm just
saying I'm pointing out this fact why do
these people have seemingly no chronic
disease
if you go back in time why did these
even even in the Western world
why were these diseases so scarce and
why are they common now well my my main
conclusion is that chronic diseases are
as someone has said they've might be
better terms and diseases of processed
food so in the late 19th century there
were technologies developed for example
that were able to make white flour there
was there was little to no white flour
before that but then they you know with
with the Industrial Revolution and these
gigantic milling machines they were able
to make white flour and everybody
started using it sugar has been around a
little bit longer but it became a lot
cheaper and so as it became cheaper and
cheaper people started using more of it
a couple hundred years ago and in the
u.s. you know per capita consumption was
like five pounds a year or something
like that whereas it's you know in the
range of 150 pounds now and then one
other one other invention that happened
in the late 19th century was they
figured out how to extract oils from
seeds so they this started out actually
as a way to try to make cotton seeds
which were a waste product profitable to
get something out of them and they did
and ultimately they made Crisco the the
laughs the CEO on that last part of
Crisco stands for cottonseed oil and
they applied this to a number you know
of different oil so now for example
soybean oil is is the most common oil
and you know corn oil canola oil you
know etc all these oils so you put those
all together and you've got modern
food and you put them you put them
together in a certain way in certain
combinations and you've got modern ultra
processed food that people eat huge
amounts of so in the United States
approximately 60% of calories in the
average diet comes from these ultra
processed foods so that's a huge amount
so these are these are the what I'm
talking about specifically are the kind
of foods that come in boxes and bags
that are brightly labeled have brand
names that are found in the middle
aisles of the supermarket and and that's
what most people eat so that is what has
caused our modern epidemic of crime
disease in my estimation now we've had
even you know a lot of this goes back to
the invention of agriculture right so
it's so before agriculture everyone was
a hunter-gatherer everyone ate meat and
whatever whatever wild vegetation they
could gather and as far as we know they
suffered from none of these scribe
diseases that we add now then when
agricultural agriculture was invented
people started eating lots of grains and
they started suffering from a lot of
chronic diseases for example a really
good example of this is that before
agriculture the average man was
something like 5 foot 9 inches tall
after agriculture they were 5 foot 3 and
there was all kinds of you know within
with his same you know proportionate
decrease in women and you know they
found in skeletons the skeletal remains
that have been studied and so on chronic
diseases osteoarthritis so on and so
forth infectious diseases also also
became very prominent at any rate we
lived like that for a long time in in
recent years
who say the 19th century people started
getting much taller again due to better
nutrition but then we took a second hit
we took this industrial food hit that I
was just talking about starting around
1900 safe heart disease started right at
rising as it as an epidemic basically in
in 1900 there was essentially zero heart
disease famous cardiologist Paul Dudley
white who was the most famous
cardiologist at mid-century said that
when he was training in the early years
of the century nobody ever talked about
coronary artery disease because nobody
had note they didn't know it existed and
then people started having heart attacks
and so on till by midnight mid 20th
century you you had huge you know huge
numbers of heart attacks and so on heart
disease epidemic so then you know fast
forward to a couple of decades ago and
then we had these Dietary Guidelines
after they decided that saturated fat
was bad and then the obesity epidemic
started going right about that time is
that a coincidence
I don't think so there are other factors
I believe but the fact that people were
told to eat less meat and animal
products and eat more carbohydrates I
believe very much contributed to it so
there we are there there's there's the
food element and that's that that is my
explanation of why this has happened and
so what it really sounds like because
it's super interesting like one is
there's a direct correlation between add
food get other problems right it's kind
of a very general way to look at that
and then the question and really where
the debate lies is like well what's bad
food and what's not
bad food I think your general kind of
conclusion sounds like real food is good
anything that's not real is worse right
now I'm just saying that it's bad it's
just when given the choice between two
separate types of meals if one is made
with real food that doesn't come with
the oils and the process process all
that kind of stuff versus the stuff that
does that real food will in almost every
way be better for you said correct that
that is correct
now there's you know there's endless
debate in like in my corner of Twitter
for example about you know what
constitutes the best diet what what
should be what should human beings
really be eating optimally and so on and
so forth but I think as you just put it
that is a very fundamental divide there
so like for example you have you have
the vegans so now vegans I mean I I
don't have a lot of sympathy for
veganism nevertheless you know they will
point out well you know a whole food
plant-based diet makes people healthier
and there's you know a fair amount of
evidence that yeah it does and in my
view the reason for that is because
they've stopped eating processed garbage
so when you talk about a whole food
plant-based diet it's not the
plant-based it's the whole food that
makes the difference so you know you you
could also formulate different diets but
if you're talking about using these
ultra-processed foods these these you
know garbage foods then you know those
are those are gonna be bad so like I say
you know there there's a lot of debate
about what constitutes the optimal or
the best and I have my own opinions on
that but yes this what you just
mentioned real whole food versus alter
process
is just a fundamental base there yeah
it's almost like look whether you want
to go vegan paleo whatever else diet
that everyone is you know kind of
debating everyone pretty much agrees
eating processed food is bad right and
so if you can if you can stop doing that
as step one for most people listening to
this like you're headed in the right
direction and then everything else is
kind of optimizing from there right
right and I think that you know that a
lot of the people live the vegans for
example who proselytize for their diet
for for lack of a better word they they
don't really quite understand that they
they you know and even let's get back
from the vegans let's see even talk
about mainstream health authorities the
kind of stuff that you'll there be an
article in New York Times so-and-so says
this and this they don't seem to realize
the difference either they they don't
seem to get for the most part that that
you know these all processed foods are
causing the problem the for example the
the oils that I mentioned so I refer to
them as seed oils they're more commonly
known as vegetable oils but they're not
made out of vegetables they're made out
of this mass industrial process from
seeds in any case they're still widely
recommended by health authorities that
you know we should be using them and so
on so forth so a lot of that just goes
they they just don't get it
unfortunately yeah and and what do you
eat on a daily basis so processed food
is bad kind of how do you come out on
this in terms of what solution you found
for yourself and and I should have
caveated at the beginning you are I'm 32
years old you are not 32 you frankly
look like you're in your mid-40s but how
old are you
I'm 65 I just got on Medicare a couple
months ago you should would be the
poster boy for moving the Medicare age
up you do not look like you're 65 years
old so what are you eating on a day to
day basis so I guess you could probably
characterize it as low carb and very
meat based so I eat meat and eggs
basically a lot of them and I eat non
starchy vegetables and I drink coffee
and tea and some red wine and I think a
little bit of dairy so you know some no
sugar yogurt that is some cheese that
sort of thing that about covers it for
the most part you know unless I'm
cheating or something got it and then
I'm really interested and we'll get to
some of the anti-aging stuff in a little
bit but part of the diet is when you eat
right and so the two things that is
really interesting to me and I cheated a
little bit because I spent a lot of time
looking at like David Sinclair's work
around longevity and all of this but one
of the key pieces is caloric restriction
right and so there's kind of two ways to
do it either one literally eat less
which can be very difficult for a lot of
people today especially in today's
society or this idea of intermittent
fasting which has you know frankly
appeared to explode in popularity and I
think that you do the intermittent
fasting as well I do
so intermittent fasting is just going
yeah like you said it's exploited in
popularity so I don't know how much of
an explanation people need but yes it's
just a practice of going without food
for some length of time and there are
there are a number of intermittent
fasting regimens I mean you know the
tons of different ones almost as many as
you know the number of people who
practice it right so 16/8 is a very
and one and that's what I usually do so
that just means nothing nothing
to eat after the evening meal then sleep
time counts as well and then not having
anything to eat in the morning until
approximately 16 hours after you the
evening meal the night before
so you mentioned caloric restriction so
yeah this is interesting from an
anti-aging point of view because many
decades ago scientists working with lab
animals found out that if you fed
animals less they lived longer and they
had less disease and so on and the idea
that all diseases are inhibited means
that aging itself is inhibited so
caloric restriction has has you know
turned out to be the most robust most
reproducible life extension intervention
that scientists have haven't found so
like you say caloric restriction is very
difficult to do and in my view is not
really necessary so there are people
there are people who practise caloric
restriction there is a calorie
restriction Society that you know with I
think several thousands of members who
do this or weigh their food very
carefully every day and all this and
they're all very lean and so on
but there's there's an easier way and
intermittent fasting appears to be just
as effective as caloric restriction for
life context extension but without back
really actual caloric restriction I mean
you know for example myself and other
people who practice intermittent fasting
we're abnormal weight right if we're not
you know super skinny or something like
that so you know presumably I and and
those other people are eating you know a
normal amount of calories so you know
what it appears to be is
it's it's a [ __ ] it's a hormetic stress
that gets into another topic but it's a
stress much like exercises a stress that
results in the organism becoming
healthier so yes intermittent fasting I
practice it many people do it it also
appears to be pretty effective for
weight loss from from when combined with
a decent diet because people simply have
difficulty eating as much during the
time when they're eating you know that
that they skipped before so yes
intermittent fasting I and a lot of
people do it very very healthy practice
well what is the target number of
calories that like the caloric
restriction community what do they
normally try to target is there's some
kind of either one set number or two
some math that they do well you know as
far as the people doing it I am Not sure
but in the laboratory when when they've
studied animals they found that
basically the more restriction the
longer they live I mean they've taken
anyway anywhere from 10 to 50 percent of
you know fewer calories for these
animals and you know and and and the
more restriction the longer they seem to
live yeah that's absolutely crazy and
then in in terms of kind of the diet
right so the takeaway is really for me
are eat less processed food I think
maybe Sinclair talked about this in one
of his books too is this idea of when
you eat is almost more important than
what you eat in some circumstances right
so kind of caloric restriction or
intermittent fasting but then you
overlay exercise on it right and I think
that most people if I said to them hey
you are tasked with losing 10 pounds
they would immediately one think of
exercise right they wouldn't think of
die
it which obviously is a it's kind of a
false way of thinking about it but to is
the type of exercise they say oh I'm
gonna go wrong right and I'm gonna go
run as far as I can for as long as I can
and hope to god that I lose weight
obviously you have a very different view
of the world so he kind of helped me
understand why you again kind of go
rogue from the traditional exercise
advice right very interesting question
this this is another topic where people
have it just all all the wrong way
around so yeah so yeah you know if you
if you told somebody they had to lose
ten pounds and they think about exercise
so that that's the common idea I'm gonna
go burn it off and and there are a
number of things wrong with that idea
first of all the evidence is is very
poor so you know as you can imagine
there been a lot of studies of this sort
of thing you know where they take a
group of people and want them lose
weight so one group will exercise and
one one won't and so on and if it's not
coupled with diet it is almost
completely ineffective it just doesn't
work exercise alone and there there
there are reasons for that good reasons
for that one is that you don't burn as
much energy exercising as most people
think right I mean you can go have a
pretty solid aerobic workout in the gym
and you know you might have you know for
30 40 minutes or something like that you
might end up burning 300 calories you
know and then you go Starbucks
afterwards get a Frappuccino which is
400 calories well that you know that's
all shot and and that leads to a
corollary which is that exercise makes
you hungry so people exercise more
thinking they're burning all off but
then they just get hungrier and they eat
more and so on in fact it's really
interesting it there there were doctors
in the 19th century that said that if
you want to lose weight stop exercising
and if you want to gain weight
exercise so you know a completely
different point of view
so my point of view as far as exercise
and weight loss is that you're not you
don't exercise to to to burn fat or burn
calories or whatever so that you know
diet diet is just supremely important in
in in weight loss so you know if you
won't if you wanna lose weight you know
using the the Pareto rule it's you know
it's eighty to ninety percent of it is
gonna be your diet however exercise
resistance training is important so one
one big problem with conventional
reducing diets so you know low calorie
diet which is you know the most common
thing portion control all this sort of
thing is that if good measures aren't
taken a lot of the weight loss is muscle
and they you know anywhere from a
quarter up to half of weight loss can be
muscle and that is something that you
really want to avoid at all costs if you
when people talk about I want to lose
weight its fat they want to lose not
muscle not not the rest of their body
weight right so resistance training is
important in my view when people are
wanting to lose weight because it helps
them build in and retain their muscle
yeah and part of this is you know
getting all goes back to science which
is if you have two people who weighed
the exact same so let's say you have a
you know 180-pound man one has lean
muscle mass and the other does not even
though they weigh the same amount from
like a pound standpoint their bodies are
actually in very different states right
that the lean muscle mass kind of more
actively burns the calories versus not
having that and that's really what it
sounds like a lot of the work that
you've done is to drive people to
not be a scare of of kind of developing
that lean muscle mass but actually
seeking it out right and trying to put
your body in a position where the
muscles themselves are burning the fat
or burning the calories and therefore
the diet plus that lean muscle mass
really does the work for you right the
you know the example you gave a you know
- two men each weighing 180 pounds but
with with different body composition if
you know is a good one because they do
not have the same health risks at all
so the health risks that are associated
with being overweight or obese are due
to body fat and they're not due to
muscles so you know this this is one of
the drawbacks of the most commonly used
measure body mass index so it's an idea
you know it's a good idea to do to
normalize body weight for how tall you
are and and so on but the fact is is you
know there are you know athletes mainly
and some other people who you know are
clinically overweight or even obese but
it's all muscle and and they don't have
the health risks conversely there are
people who are normal weight there's a
phenomenon called normal weight obesity
and they have a very high level of body
fat even though they are a normal weight
and they have the exact same health
risks as somebody who is obese so yeah
it's all driven by body fat the more
muscle and less body fat you have within
limits of course but you know speaking
very generally the healthier you are the
the more it's not just it's not even
just a matter of the muscle burning the
calories to keep you at a normal weight
it's also a matter of your metabolism is
functioning properly so that you don't
have these high risks
of all the chronic diseases that are so
rampant in our society type 2 diabetes
has just risen
you know tremendously like something
like eight to ten fold you know just in
the last several decades so those those
of us who talk about this topic I think
are very well aware of this but I think
this is this one fact is not very well
appreciated by most people who don't
take a deep look at it and that is that
type 2 diabetes is just the end result
of a long chain of events that that lead
ultimately to type 2 diabetes so it's so
if somebody becomes diabetic when their
blood sugar is no longer under control
and it rises but all the events that
lead to that are happening in the vast
majority of people in the United States
today there was a recent study that
showed that 88 percent of American
adults had some kind of metabolic
dysfunction and only 12% were were
clinically metabolically healthy so what
that means is that all those people that
88% there they're traveling on traveling
that road to type 2 diabetes that's the
road you want to stay off and by having
good body composition which is a high
relatively high level of muscle a little
body fat for both men and women you stay
off that road yeah one of the
interesting things I saw you talk about
I think it was in a article he wrote was
the difference in using like a body mass
index as a measurement for health versus
literally just measuring somebody's
waistline right so maybe kind of talk
about that that kind of the difference
there and most people hear that they
kind of like less really simplistic but
but but you you know you may basically
the argument like hey literally
measuring the waistline could be a
better way to measure health right right
and and it is so body mass index
you know like I was just saying it
doesn't take into account the
proportions of muscle and body fat that
somebody has so a very simple measure
and this has been studied a lot is and
in I want it let me back up just a
little bit I just want to say a lot of
people make this point about that I just
made about okay they're all the you know
there are these athletes that you know
that have a high body mass index but
they're in good health and so on and I
yeah you know sure I agree however that
just just does not apply to most people
BMI is actually more likely to
underestimate health risks because of
this phenomenon of normal weight obesity
right so people have high body fat and
they look according to bf mi they look
normal when in fact they have high
health risks in any case yeah waist size
is actually better so if somebody is
there their waist size should be 1/2 or
less of their height and that is a
better measure of metabolic and crying
disease risk than body mass index really
so if somebody is 6 feet 6 feet tall
they should have a 36 inch or less waist
size to be healthy yeah it's pretty
crazy how you know once you start to
wrap your head around this stuff it
simple to understand what the benchmarks
are and kind of where we're gonna fall
the hard work is in is really
disciplined one of the things that I
know a lot of people so I was military
played football in college and there was
always kind of weird sayings that at the
time seemed a little crazy but but as
you learn more may not be so crazy so I
literally would have a friend who would
always say I always will be able to run
a sub seven-minute mile and I just give
him [ __ ] and say like you know why and
he said you ever seen a fat person who
can run some seven minutes ok like you
know like that there's some truth to
that I guess
and then many of those people both from
military and from from playing football
have now gone on to do a lot of this
like high-intensity training so whether
it's CrossFit or other types of
exercises they have elements of strength
training but they also have kind of a
cardiovascular element to them as well
packed into you know somewhat short 30
to 45 minutes I work out what's kind of
your take on that and how does that fit
into kind of the the exercise type
routines that you think work best for
people yeah that that's that's
interesting so high intensity training
you know is a is a relatively recent
phenomenon as far as that's been studied
by exercise physiologist and so on and
the results have been remarkable in in
the lab studies they've done on this I
mean for example one one study they had
they had people riding on a stationary
bicycle so they would go all out before
30 seconds I believe it was and then
have a you know then they would cycle
leisurely for a few minutes and then do
it again so for a total of three all-out
bouts on the exercise cycle meanwhile
they had a group on also on an exercise
bicycle doing steady you know what we
would see like what you would typically
see when you walk into a gym people
pedaling on their cycle so steady-state
aerobic exercise for 45 minutes
so these these groups each did three
sessions a week and in just a few weeks
the people that were literally only
working out I don't know what it came to
six minutes a week or something God just
as fit as the people who spent 45
minutes a day riding their their
exercise bicycles so by ramping up the
intensity of the exercise you you you
decrease the the need for duration
and for frequency so yeah high-intensity
exercise is great how that fits into my
philosophy of exercise is high-intensity
resistance training so that's that's the
for my practice and that I advocate and
there are a lot of you know mistaken
ideas about it but because it doesn't
necessarily people hear this word
high-intensity I think oh my god you
know it's you know I'm not gonna do that
in a duct but it does not necessarily
involve what most people think of is
heavy weights and it doesn't involve
moving quickly either in fact quite the
opposite
it's slow movements generally speaking
but it involves basically doing a set
until momentary muscular failure which
means until you cannot do another rep so
this turns out to be a very good
cardiovascular exercise as well because
it's a form of high-intensity training
that's what I do that's what I advocate
and so like let's take a simple exercise
like the bench press right
walk me through kind of how much weight
right so fifty percent a hundred percent
of somebody's kind of one rep max and
then what does that look like from a
number of reps that they normally would
be able to do right so if somebody came
to you and said hey I'm gonna go
benchpress today how do I do the
high-intensity resistance training what
does that look like right so as far as
the the weight goes if somebody is is
moving to a high-intensity way of
training the the choice of a weight is
gonna be a little bit of trial and error
at first as compared to say what they do
on a one repetition max lived-in
in general the first a couple of reps
should be relatively easy you should be
able to always move in good form you
should always be able to control the
weight without heaving or jerking the
weight around
now bench-pressed is is perhaps not the
best example of what I want to
illustrate here and and the reason for
that is because in a bench press you
have the possibility of a barbell with
weights getting stuck on your chest and
you don't want that to happen so you
know I always tell people that being
free of injury is the most important
thing you can do as far as any form of
exercise that's just the most important
aspect of it so if somebody who wanted
to do a bench press
to momentary muscular failure they
should either have a spotter or a chest
press machine would probably be better
for the average person so they're going
to move that weight in you know slowly
and in good form and do it until they
can no longer do another repetition now
in terms of reps repeted repetitions are
not the goal repetitions are a way of
keeping count so the number of
repetitions that anyone can do is going
to vary between you know the person
who's doing it how much weight they
choose and so on what you want to look
at is time under tension and going into
momentary muscular failure so a fairly
wide range of of time under tension is a
totally effective for building muscle
and for getting fit so I usually tell
people you know 30 to 60 seconds maybe a
little more of time under tension is
about where you want to be reps or a
method of keeping count not your goal
and always go to momentary muscular
failure for sure one of the things and
this is it's been years since since I
looked at this so you'll have to excuse
me if I misspeak here but there was a
gentleman who
I want to say was an Arizona he was
playing college football I think maybe
even watch the NFL I do not think it was
Pat Tillman but it could have been him
there's somebody and basically what they
were doing is they were training with
somebody who the entire thought process
was that time under tension didn't have
to only be arrived at through repetition
right so if I wanted to for example put
my pectoral muscles through time under
tension I could do that simply by going
down into a push-up position kind of at
the at the most tension point and just
holding it and then I could hold it for
60 seconds come out of it and I would
get the same if not more benefit than
the person who sat down and did you know
10 or 15 reps at whatever the weight was
and I always thought that was
interesting because to a lay person like
me who has no scientific background
other than what Google provides um it
makes sense right but but but it was
just very interesting cuz again that was
a different view of the world but seem
to arrive at the same conclusion so just
interested on your thoughts there if
that has any validity or ladies been
disproven at this point no no it's it's
absolutely correct so what you're
interested in is the the muscle doing
metabolic work and so that this actually
leads to an interesting point you know
what what is the purpose of lifting
weights so if you ask the average person
an average guy in the gym you know what
you're supposed to do in the weight room
he says well it's to pick up a weight
and to move it in a certain way and move
it you know and move it back again and I
think that's that's an incorrect answer
the answer is you're supposed to load
your muscle your load your muscles with
tension and work your muscles with this
tension until you you get to momentary
muscular failure in order to put the
proper stress on your muscles that will
make them stronger
make them grow so as far as what you're
talking about the this you know being
stationary certainly you can go down
into a push-up position and as long as
you're not locked out at the top but if
you're just half way there
you're certainly putting your muscles
under tension you stay there you you are
exercising them and you can provide the
stimulus for your muscles to get
stronger by doing that yeah it's super
interesting and then I guess you know
there's the diet and exercise component
that we've talked about but ultimately a
lot of this feeds into the anti-aging
kind of talk tracker or thought process
and to me anti-aging has kind of two
components right the average person
simply wants to have a healthier life
right so they think hey the average
person dodged around 77 years old give
or take that's what I'm gonna die you
know based on the data I want to be as
healthy and happy as I can be for my 77
years here on earth and you know see you
guys later there is another group that
basically says if 77 is the average I
want to live to you know 150 and and
kind of they actually want to extend
life
diet and exercise plays into both of
those categories of longevity correct
right sure
yeah so is I I'm sorry do you did you
want to complete that where you were
saying yeah well just like how do you
think about let's take the first bucket
first right so like hey I want to be
healthier for the time I am allotted
here
diet and exercise feeding into that is
basically what you focused on right
right so yes this is a very interesting
question
so I think most people think about this
in the wrong way so the idea of
anti-aging or life extension most people
the the really most common reaction is
people think that means they're gonna
spend an extra decade in a nursing home
and that is absolutely not what we're
about here so there there are a couple
of concepts well there's a concept that
I think is helpful in thinking about
that and that is healthspan so people
talk about lifespan you want to have a
health health span to write the typical
the typical way that people live now
that is that somewhere in middle age
they developed some health problems and
they gradually go downhill for a long
time for decades until finally they get
to the end of the road ideally you would
want I mean we know we're all gonna get
to the end of the road someday but
ideally you want to be as healthy as
possible
while you're doing it so that any any
diseases that come along they only come
along at the end of life and that that
pattern is in fact what you see a lot of
very long-lived people they're quite
healthy until 100 or something like that
and then they come down with something
and then that's it so the other thing is
is that this is related to the first
point is that anti-aging or life
extension it is necessarily about more
years of healthy life which in which
even if it isn't a longer life it
necessarily means a healthy life most
chronic diseases occur in older age from
middle-age on up and that indicates that
they're all closely related to aging so
if you can postpone aging you you you
postpone all the diseases of Aging
that that that's that's what it amounts
to it's not about more years in a
nursing home it's about extending years
of healthy lifespan and would it be fair
to say that if you had to choose one or
the other health or a diet versus
exercise for most people the simplest
thing and that would have the biggest
impact is actually the diet side rather
than the exercise side or do you feel
like it is you have
to have both I well you know if forced
to choose I would agree with that that
diet is the most important thing and
there are a couple of reasons
one is that the amount a fairly small
amount of exercise has large benefits so
you know you don't have to be an athlete
or do all kinds of stuff they have get
large benefits just just as opposed to
being sedentary you know of course what
I advocate is people do optimal exercise
and that's what I try to do with my
resistance training and so on but but
the fact is that you you can get these
large benefits from a small amount of
exercise on the other hand there there's
an expression that people often use in
my neck of the woods is you can't outrun
a bad diet and so I mean there are cases
of athletes who have become diabetic
because they're eating the wrong diet
you know really high carb so you know
bat back in the day when I used to do a
lot of running I mean all the running
magazines are telling you to eat all
these cards all the time all the time
and you know I did that and people have
done that and they if they have become
diabetic just despite a very high level
of exercise so for those reasons yeah I
would come down on diet as being the
most important thing for most people I
think it was Von Miller a Denver Broncos
an NFL player a couple years ago he sat
out a practice right in the media of
course you hey you're like the star
player why you sitting out of practice
and anything very kind of embarrassing
Lee went in front of the cameras and he
said something to the effect of I had
mozzarella sticks yesterday and and the
quote he used was that's like putting
regular gas in a Ferrari right it just
uh it's just gonna screw it up and so he
was basically saying look you know I
felt sick because I eat so healthy I'm
such this
like you know elite athlete and then I
ate some shitty food and next thing you
know like literally I missed practice
the next day and you know look that's
like it happened to everyone every
single time whatever but it was just
very very kind of illuminating I think
when I heard him say that I said look
the guy's super in tune with his body
and obviously it had an impact for an
NFL player to miss a practice simply
because of something he ate the day
before the night before absolutely I
mean those guys need need to be careful
with what they eat and I think most of
them are I you know read a lot about Tom
Brady and his diet and he's very very
careful about it so yeah it it's very
important even even at a high level of
exercise you you you know there are some
exceptions and maybe you know for for
short periods of time like the swimmer
whose name escapes me at the moment the
Olympic medalist who is supposedly
eating 12,000 calories a day and and so
you know maybe he can get away with that
for a short period of time but you know
this this phenomenon is real about not
being able to outrun a bad diet yeah
it's pretty crazy before we go to wrap
up where where can people find out more
about you and your work where do you
want to send them sure or so thanks I my
website is called rogue health and
fitness comm and I'm very active on
twitter my handle is Mangan that's my
last name
Mangan 150 and that's where they could
find me awesome I end each episode with
the same two questions and then you'll
get to ask me a question to end in the
episode but the first one is what is the
most important book you've ever read
that's a good question I I could say
that a book that had a big impact on me
was Thoreau by a Walden by Thoreau
excuse me
I read that many times when I was young
and it impressed upon me the idea of
living life that life was to be lived I
love that I thought I see in the
background the Bitcoin billionaires I
thought you were gonna throw that out
there
well that's current reading for sure
yeah Ben Mezrich the authors been on the
podcast and he did a fantastic job with
that one but the book Walden what
exactly is is it a fiction book is it a
nonfiction it is nonfiction it was
written in 1843 I believe and Henry
David Thoreau is the author and he went
out to live in a cabin on a lake in in
Walden Pond in Massachusetts and he just
wrote about spending a year there and
it's very philosophical and there are a
number of quotes from the book that you
probably find familiar like the mass of
men lead lives of quiet desperation
there's another one about marching to a
different drummer so these these come
from that book it's about living life as
you see fit about another quote coming
to the you don't want to come to the end
of your life and find out that you have
not really lived that is a very very
true statement for sure we spent a lot
of time talking about humans and the
last question I ask is a more fun one
about aliens believer or non-believer
non-believer Wow okay why a non-believer
because the evidence shows the the
evidence points to the idea that human
beings may be unique in the universe as
far as intelligent life goes so there
may very well and probably is some form
of life elsewhere but as far as
intelligent life there I would ask the
question that Enrico Fermi asked where
are they I mean if they're question
there there are billions of galaxies and
vast space and and it's all been in
existence for billions of years why
haven't we heard from anybody why isn't
there any sign of anything I think that
is the most compelling anti-alien
argument that there is I've had you know
hundreds of people at this point I've
asked this question to on the podcast
and I'd say 95% of people believe and
they basically sum it up to like it
would be ignorant for us to not believe
and the world is so vast and you know
they're kind of all that but there's
only one answer that I ever hear on the
anti belief side that makes sense to me
and it's that which is hey they're not
real until we find them or they find us
right right
they're just you know you couple that
with some theoretical thinking about the
the odds of intelligent life evolving
and so on and the fact that that we
don't have any evidence for that and
there ought to be abundant evidence one
would think so so at the moment I'm in
I'm in the negative camp I love it I
love it what's the one question you have
for me to wrap this up I am curious
about your your work day you seem to be
incredibly hard-working
you put out your letter five days a week
you do regular podcasts I think maybe
five five a week or so how the hell do
you do it yeah I um I have this a weird
framework I somebody every asked me this
recently so I have an advantage and that
I took some time to think about it and
what I told them was I've really
compartmentalized my day and there's a
certain rhythm to it and I know myself
well enough I take the the letter I read
every morning day that I stopped writing
that it's over like like the streaks
broke in I'll be done right and so I
just know every day I got to write
something and no matter what happens I
gotta write it and then I'll worry about
tomorrow if tomorrow's gonna be the day
I stop right and then on the video on
the podcast stuff like I get to learn
from people who have spent like you know
take yourself for example he's got a
bunch of time thinking about things that
I don't spend a lot of time thinking
about I probably should spend more time
and so you helped me just kind of cheat
a little bit in that you downloaded all
your information to me right and it just
so happens that we recorded it and bunch
of other people are gonna listen so I
think that it's um it's all really
around learning and and I generally
enjoy doing that and so it's kind of
like I would spend my time doing this
even if no one was reading it or
listening at the same time you who is it
a jackal will Nick I think has a thing
of like disciplined equals freedom right
and it's this idea of just I know every
day here's how my day is split up I know
exactly how to kind of allocate that
time people who are close to me will
tell you I will get a little annoyed if
I feel like it's off right so of all of
a sudden I realize hey I don't have to
letter written by a certain time I know
I'm behind and then it's like I better
speed this up before everything else
gets set off and and so when you kind of
get in a rhythm and have some sort of
process and
have some discipline around it it's
comes second nature right so like I
literally don't even I don't even know
what I would do in the morning if I
didn't write the letter Rex I just been
doing it for so long that it's just like
well done of course I do that but at the
same time I have had friends who I've
got one who actually works for works
with a gentleman who writes a very
popular email every day and he's got
five people working on it and I asked
well sighs what the hell do you guys all
do like a little if I had five people I
don't even know what I would have them
do they were all sit there and watch me
write pretty much right like that was
kind of weird so I do think that it it's
like anything right if you enjoyed doing
it it's not even work it's just like I'm
excited to you know have the
conversations or or write the stuff and
you know everyone somewhere I get
reminded like that's not normal but yeah
there's things that you do every single
day that that I'm like wow that's not
normal but to you is a second nature and
something you enjoy right that that
that's that's great too
your explanation is great I really
admire what you do and we are in a
stance you and I are in a sense in the
same space and that we're both online
this is all you know relatively new I
mean I up until a year ago I was working
my day job you know as well as doing all
this other stuff now I'm doing this
exclusively so I really like to see how
somebody like yourself goes about it
it's similar to what I do although you
sound like more disciplined than I am
and and yeah yeah what I would say too
is I think the tools have changed right
you know so if you just take literally
everything from emails to podcasts all
this kind of stuff like there was a day
and age one of the things that really
surprised me but was very kind of cool
to hear was Joe Rogan recently had Tom
Green did The Canadian comedian who was
you know a bunch of movies and stuff
back in the day
come on his podcast and the reason why
he did that
was that Tom green used to have a show
like a literally like a TV station
basically out of his house and Joe Rogan
went on as a guest in like 2007 and
there was a clip that went viral
recently from that day that they
recorded and Joe Rogan's like a little
kid in a candy store he's like looking
around and he's like oh my god dude this
is awesome like oh my god you turned
your house into you know a video set and
light bulb goes off like you just see
the wheels were spinning and so he
Friday it's Tom Green and two or three
other people with really pushing him
down the path of creating what
eventually became the podcast he runs
and so when Tom Green came back recently
they had this whole conversation where
he was literally buying servers and
putting them in his house and every six
months it seemed like there's new
technology and his was outdated and had
have a whole staff and anybody who was
running a television production studio
right and then YouTube was born and now
you and I can record a video and put it
on YouTube right and like what like were
spoiled compared to just 15 years ago
what somebody would have to do and so I
do think that like the technology kind
of advancement that that evolution cycle
has put us at a time in place in the
world where like we can do this pretty
effortlessly in terms of like we can
just focus on the content and we don't
have to worry about a lot of the
infrastructure because there's so many
solutions you know everything from
Amazon as a marketplace to Shopify to
you know email providers all kinds of
stuff absolutely I feel incredibly
fortunate to you know be able to take
advantage of it I mean there was I think
I was 43 the first time I went on the
Internet
I mean it wasn't around you know so you
know now I get a laptop and I go online
and and there you go it doesn't doesn't
require a lot else it's it's fantastic I
love that I I I could not imagine having
never been raised on 32 have never
on the internet and then go another 10
years and that's the first time you get
on the Internet like the idea that I can
use this thing to get access to
information to people so all these
different things had to be just a wild
experience yeah it was it was very wild
for me I mean I I used to I remember
going on in thinking wow like there's a
webcam in the Antarctic oh my god you
know that is incredible and I can see
what's going on there right now you know
you know little did I know what was to
come but you know before that you know
to get information you had to go to a
library which I did of course but but
now I mean you know the world is the
world is out there at your fingertips
and as far as the business aspect of it
goes I mean you know yeah it's great I
mean I I think you mentioned Joe Rogan I
mean what he's done is just astounding
to me and you know you're you're perhaps
on your way to Rogen them there you know
with what you're doing I think that's
great and so I'm always interested in
seeing and you know really admire what
you're doing awesome well I am just as
much of a fan of your work as well so I
think people will really enjoy this and
as you as you keep going what to do to
get in the future okay all right well
thank you very much